>> THIS MARKS THE 71st
ANNIVERSARY OF D-DAY.
WE'LL BE IN MORMA
WE'LL BE IN MOR
WE'LL BE IN NORMAN DAY DANDY.
YOU'VE BEEN TALKING TO SOME OF
THE WORLD WAR II VETERAN, WHAT
DID YOU FIND?
>> BEFORE WE FOUND THE UNITED
STATES IN NEW ORLEANS, I SPOKE
TO BEN MARTINEZ.
HE SIGNED UP TO SERVE IN WORLD
WAR II, HE WAS 72 YEARS OLD.
HE SERVED IN ITALY, WE TALKED
ABOUT HOW D-DAY LET TO THE END
OF THE THE WAR AND WHAT THAT
MEANT TO HIM, WATCH.
>> I WANTED TO GET IN RIGHT AWAY
AT PEARL HARBOR, BUT I WAS
ADVISED NOT TO.
I HAD -- AND EVERYBODY SAID GET
YOUR DEGREE FIRST AND THEN
ENLIST.
SO I ENLISTED IN MAY OF '42.
GOT OUT IN THE MAY OF '46.
>> BEN MARTINEZ SERVE IN THE
ITALIAN CAMPAIGN AS A MEDIC.
HE AND HIS TEAM TRAVERSED THE
ITALIAN ALPS WHILE A DONKEY
CARRIED SUPPLIES.
HE STILL REMEMBERS THE DAY HE
RECEIVED WORD THAT THE WAR WAS
OVER.
>> WE WERE AT A LITTLE TOWN
CALLED OGBOW.
WE WERE LOADING UP THE MULE, WE
WERE IN THE ALPS, WE WERE GOING
TO GO UP HIGHER.
WE WERE LOADING UP THE MULES
WHEN THE WORD CAME DOWN, THE WAR
WAS OVER.
IT WAS COMPLETE SILENCE.
NOBODY TALKED TO ANYBODY.
I THINK THEY ALL HAD THEIR OWN
THING GOING ON.
WHEN I CAME TO, MORE OR LESS,
THE FIRST THING I DID WAS WENT
TO SEE THE MAN LOADING UP THE
MULES.
AND I THINK I STARTED CRYING.
IT'S OVER.
YOU GUYS DON'T HAVE TO DO WHAT
YOU DID BEFORE.
IT'S OVER.
>> BEN MARTINEZ CAME OVER AT THE
SUMMER OF '45.
AT NEARLY 100, HE VOLUNTEERS TWO
DAYS A WEEK AT THE NATIONAL
WORLD WAR II MUSEUM IN NEW
ORLEANS SHARING FIRSTHAND
STORIES ONLY HE CAN TELL AND
REMEMBERING THOSE WHO WERE NEVER
ABLE TO TELL THEIR STORIES.
>> LAURA, THAT IS WHAT WE WILL
BE DOING THIS WEEK, TELLING THE
STORIES OF THE CIVILIAN HEROES
WHO TRULY SAVED THE WORLD AS WE
KNOW IT, THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
SACRIFICE, THE COMMITMENT TO THE
SHARED CAUSE IS SOMETHING WE
LOST AND SOMETHING I HOPE TO
REMIND THE YOUNG PEEP.
>> THE YOUNG PEOPLE --
>> WE KNOW THE STORIES, SO
COMPELLING TO HEAR.
BUT THE YOUNG PEOPLE, I HOPE,
ARE GOING TO TAKE THE MOST OUT
OF THIS WEEK OF COMMEMORATION
AND MEMORIES.
THERE ARE NOT MANY LEFT.
THIS WILL BE THE LAST MAJOR
ANNIVERSARY TO CELEBRATE.
I REMEMBER REAGAN DID THE
SAME -- THE BOYS -- THEY TOOK
THE CLIP.
>> YEAH.
>> Laura: AND TOMORROW, WE'LL BE
OUT ON THE STREETS WITH THE
PROTESTERS.
>> TODAY THE PROTESTERS WERE
THIN.
THERE WERE ONLY A HANDFUL
OUTSIDE OF BUCKINGHAM PALACE.
>> Laura: THERE THEY ARE.
>> THOSE ARE THE TWO.
IT WAS A THIN CROWD.
TOMORROW THEY EXPECT THOUSANDS
IN TRAFALGAR SQUARE.